I come from Earth a planet about laws my
name is Peter quill there's one other
name you might know me by star-lord who
star-lord man
legendary out Locke guys forget it
[Applause]
[Music]
so here we are a thief two thugs
an assassin and a maniac but we're not
gonna stand by his evil wipes out of the
galaxy I guess we're stuck together
partners are you telling me the fate of
12 billion people
is in the hands of these criminals yeah
[Music]
I look around you know what I see losers
but life is giving us a chance
to do something good
[Music]
something bad bit of both
Oh what the hell I don't got that long a
lifespan anyway
it might not be the best idea hey
youtubers it's Charlie so we just got a
brand-new trailer for guardians of the
galaxy we got a nice full look at Ronan
the accuser and the accused core as well
as the collector so for my Marvel bonus
video this week I'm just gonna do a
breakdown of all the new things in my
top 5 moments so here we go number 5 the
music yes it's a little bit ridiculous
they kept hooked on a feeling from the
last trailer but they also added spirit
in the sky it ties into Peter Quill's
anachronistic taste in music
he listens to classic rock and flies a
spaceship that as well as all of them
being a bunch of well-meaning dirtbags
really sets this funny tone for the
movie that I think everyone's gonna
really really enjoy the Avengers was
funny I mean it was just Whedon
hilarious but this is turning the knob
to 11 it's gonna be so bonkers you have
no idea and I'm so excited to see it
number four group speaks so Vin Diesel
actually is just doing a Q&A this
morning and he said he probably said I
am Groot about a thousand times in the
recording booth he has language like a
real language but only Rocket Raccoon
can understand him it's a lot like Han
Solo and Chewbacca a really furry short
Han Solo and a really tall fibrous
Chewie we also get to see some of his
powers he does have some unique
abilities including the ability to
regrow himself from a single piece of
his skin like a Spore he regenerates
because the skin and limbs just get
chipped off all the time that flower tea
he handed to the little girl also
probably grew off of him we also got to
see him pop spike Suns back you know
like Wolverine pops his claws I'm really
interested to see some of his armor
based powers mostly just watching him
get blown up and they just regrow
himself number three we got to hear Nova
prime Clank close we didn't see her but
she is playing Nova prime the leader of
the Nova Corps think of her is like a
giant step up from Cobie Smulders in
Winter Soldier
she's like the Nick Fury of the Galactic
version of shield they've really been
pushing john c reilly though as the face
of the core and all the trailers so i'm
guessing he's just gonna be spending way
more face time with the guardians way
more than Glenn Close but a lot of
people are also wondering if there's
gonna be any references to Nova as in
Nova the superhero like in Easter eggs
he's not supposed to be in the movie but
I do have my fingers crossed they're
gonna include some references to him I'm
thinking they might
actually hold Nova back for one of the
sequels though the one of the guardians
of the galaxy sequels number two a
full-on shot of the collector so it's
also kind of implied that he'll be
working for or working with fan OHS in
the movie obviously because Stannis is
such a huge deal he's planning to be in
any of these early trailers but
supposedly Marvel has cast him already
and he's a big part of the story those
are all just rumors so take it with a
grain of salt the collector is just
gonna be the most visible antagonist in
the movie he's obviously trying to
collect all the infinity gems and as of
the end of Thor the dark world he has a
couple of them already and my number one
moment
Ronan the accuser so we finally got to
see a full-on shot of Ronan and the
accuser core that's what those hammers
are it really reminds you visually of
Thor which is kind of funny the accuser
core is his army of Kree soldiers Ronan
is a Kree which serves justice in their
territory of the galaxy they're like an
opposing but equal force to the Nova
Corps lots of different galactic
organizations out there but this movie
will set the stage to go way beyond the
small shield earth-based stuff that
we've been saying since the first
Avengers movie
Ronan for the most part is an antagonist
to the Guardians but he has worked with
them in the past in the comics as well
as the Avengers so he is more of like a
Darth Vader to the collectors Emperor
although he's not necessarily a servant
nebula though Karen Gillan's character
is a full-on villain I am so excited to
see her she'll also be working for the
collector with Ronan mostly with Ronan
though they haven't really released any
information about how this movie is
going to tie into Avengers 2 because
that's the next movie other than the
MacGuffin of the infinity gems Avengers
3d is really when those are gonna become
a big part of the story so I'm not
expecting too many Avengers shoutouts in
this movie but we might get another
Avengers post-credits scene or maybe
even see an ant-man teaser since that's
the next movie after Avengers 2 but now
it's your turn let me know below in the
comments what was your favorite moment
seeing Groot speak for the first time or
getting a good look at the accuser core
but in other news my Marvel bonus video
this week is basically this video but if
you guys want me to do a Marvel Q&A I'll
do that tomorrow on Tuesday because I'm
also gonna be doing a Star Wars bonus
video so be sure to subscribe to get
everything and feel free to leave me
suggestions for topics that you guys
want to talk about thank you so much for
watching right now you can actually
click here to learn all about the new
fall TV shows that Marvel is doing
including the Netflix shows and you can
click here for my breakdown
on the Star Wars seven cast thanks for
watching I'll see you guys tonight high
fives
you